richard mirande bonjour bonjour monsieur
libéraux alors vous êtes candidat sur la
circonscription du sud et vous êtes sans
étiquette qu'est ce qui a motivé votre
candidature
alors j'aimerais bien a expliqué à la
population
l'intérêt qu'il y a 2
de participer aux différentes élections
parce que
quand il ya les élections il ya une
chose qu'on dit souvent et que les
médias disent souvent aux électeurs
c'est le grand gagnant
c'est l'abstention mais ce qu'ils
oublient de dire c'est que
les grands perdants ce sont les
abstentionnistes
pourquoi parce que quand on ne vote pas
on laisse le champ libre à la corruption
aux grands dinosaures deux parties qui
viennent en quelque sorte surtout pour
les législatives engranger de l'argent
pour leur parti pour faire
les affaires des partis tandis qu'un
député quand il reçoit des sommes il a
diverse enveloppe où ils peuvent
investir et
construire ce qu'on n'a jamais constitué
en martinique c'est une politique pour
le territoire martinique une ligne et le
député aussi est là pour ouvrir
il ouvre les portes
la houle et les
citoyens les gens du pays le peuple ne
peut pas aller on peut lui rapporter les
choses et lui il va ouvrir ses portes là
au nom du peuple alors ce moment est-ce
qu'il faut rendre le vote obligatoire
alors vendre le moindre le vote
obligatoire c'est moi je suis pas dans
une histoire d'obligations
c'est à nous d'en question d'abord de
responsabilité dress de montrent que
donner envie aux gens pour qu'ils
puissent prendre leurs responsabilités
démontrer au lieu de faire des camps
politiques d d d d
des affrontements de personnes on met la
politique dans une histoire de culte de
personnalité et on fait des fanatiques
des uns et des autres et ce sont les
fanatiques élisent des députés des dix
ans les gens qui sont au pouvoir et puis
le peuple lui-même y aurait 100
spectateurs et moi je suis là pour qu'on
puisse se dire il est temps qu'on soit
acteur de nos vies et non des figurants
halo reach a remis rente vous vous
inscrivez dans une convergence de lutte
martinique guadeloupe guyane réunion et
réunion et mayotte qu'est-ce que cela
signifie
sans oublier la kanaky c'est que grâce
aux mouvements des gilet jaune
on a réussi à ceux à se connecter entre
nous par le biais de d'une télé web et
on a développé les différents problèmes
les soucis que nous avons les
différentes actions menées pour pouvoir
s'en sortir nous partageons ça depuis
près de trois ans et de ce fait on s'est
dit mais
si nous voulons vraiment que cette
convergence se fasse eh bien nous devons
nous donner les moyens de le faire dalé
de se rencontrer et d'aller ensemble
défendre nos territoires
pour
l'avenir politique et civilisationnel de
nos territoires donc on s'est dit
allez-y entre nous on y va et ce n'est
pas chose facile parce que dans le
militantisme
c'est qui a compliqué sur notre
territoire le militantisme dur pour eux
ce sont des trucs fois c'est on n'y va
pas dans l'étude français par contre
l'étude française sont donc toutes nos
affaires ici et ben ouais mais dimaga
ladd a bien quels sont les grands thèmes
que vous souhaitez développer pendant la
campagne alors moi je ne développe pas
de gants m jeudi déjà s'il faut donner
deux trois trucs je dirais que je veux
défendre les biens et les personnes dans
nos territoires donc s'il faut porter un
premier truc ce serait tout les
histoires de terre volée qui a en
martinique
protéger la biodiversité parce que quand
je regarde comment on vient nous dire
qui à la pollution on essaie de trouver
un moyen de dire aux martiniquais il
faudra peut-être pas prendre votre
voiture at elle est là mais quand je
regarde je me réveille il n'y a pas un
arbre qui bouge en martinique la
martinique et déjà pour lui quand est ce
qu'on va aller dire aux gens qui
polluent le monde entier que vous êtes
en train d'impacter la martinique que
vous êtes entrain de réchauffer la
planète la martinique perd de sa
grandeur alors qu'ils à pitti excusez
moi quand on vois je vois des gens qui
vont à pâques ou là bientôt vision au
bord de mer est bien là où on pourrait
dire où est presque là bas langlois
avant cela n'était qu'un copie d'accords
donc on doit avoir des gens capables de
défendre ses études là et la théorie de
l apparence qui se trouve au tribunal il
faut pas que ça devienne une loi en
trente secondes c'est la dernière
question qu'avez vous donc à dire au
peuple et pour convaincre ce peuple de
footy pour vous
eh bien c'est exactement ce que j'avais
déjà dire que j'avais déjà dit je vais
encore le redire c'est prenez vos
responsabilités
ne votez pas parce que et c'est
l'attaqué la manga niveau des bains ou
bien y est c'est un tel nom écouter
vraiment si vous voulez savoir moi je
vous demande de venir sur le compte
facebook de soupe à isla est super à
lille 2 et c'est là et j'ai plein de
choses à vous dire merci beaucoup
richard miron et je vous remercie merci
à vous